I have sad news for you and it really is
sad I'm not being satirical in any way
the next democratic debate is going to
be the worst one yet and this is cos
previous Democratic debates have been
this election cycle the next one which
is number four in the middle of this
month will be the worst one because the
requirements to get into the debate
aren't strict enough at this late stage
in the game just a couple of months from
when voting will actually start in the
Democratic primary we have 12 people
that have qualified for the fourth
debate and the entire debate is going to
take place on one night we are going to
have 12 candidates on the stage at the
same time and I've told you before 10
candidates on the stage times two nights
for 20 total candidates there are many
problems there you don't see all the
candidates on the stage together so you
can't really evaluate them on the basis
of how they all talk to each other you
had nights where Warren and Bernie were
split up you had nights where Biden was
separated from other frontrunners so
that was a problem and then at the same
time with 10 people on the stage each
night the level of depth was very low
because you had 10 people competing for
speaking time so when the number of
people who qualified for the fourth
debate which is on October 15th hit 10
and then Hetal hit 11 and then hit 12
the immediate question was are they
going to do two debates with six people
on each stage which might actually allow
for a little bit more depth even if we
are splitting up the candidates onto two
stages and the answer is no CNN which is
co-hosting this debate with the New York
Times has decided they are going to do
one night twelve candidates all on the
same stage and between CNN again
co-hosting the debate which was just
terrible last time right-wing framing of
questions we shut down my live stream of
the debate as you might remember and
more candidates than ever on the stage
at once this is just going to be
terrible that's the reality the debate
is going to be on Tuesday October 15th
at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time
we will attempt live coverage of course
and the reality is that no one can look
good with 12 people on the stage
especially when you're answering poorly
framed
chins from the moderators so who's
responsible here is it CNN in the New
York Times for wanting it to be on one
night is it the Democratic National
Committee for accepting that it all be
done on one night who has the power here
it's not completely clear but what I can
tell you for sure what is very clear is
that they are making the debates not
only unwatchable but completely useless
in terms of actually providing us with
the information that we need to
accurately and in an informed way
determine who it is we want to support
in the 2020 Democratic primary it now
let's do a little math if with 12
candidates on stage if the debate ran
three hours with no commercials that's a
hundred and eighty minutes 12 candidates
that's 15 minutes per candidate so
that's already not great look if I'm
going to decide who I'm supporting I
want to hear from them for more than
just 15 minutes but again that's with no
breaks with no anything else remember
that the last CNN debate started with
some overly produced sports game like
introduction opening statements from
candidates which I find completely
useless and a commercial break before
the first question it was 25 minutes
into the scheduled start of the debate
before the first question was asked they
also were scheduled for three hours or
maybe for two but in any case they ended
up twenty minutes shy of three hours so
you take away 25 minutes from the front
you take away 20 minutes from the end
and on that basis each candidate gets a
little over 11 minutes to speak and then
if we add in the fact that they are
taking a couple commercial breaks
throughout the entire thing what you end
up with with 12 candidates on the stage
effectively in a quote three-hour debate
is 10 minutes of speaking time per
candidate this is not how I want to pick
a presidential candidate it's
embarrassingly bad and then of course
there's also the issue of the fact that
with absolutely no chance of winning you
have candidates participating and taking
away from important conversations that
we could be having I'll give you an
example imagine if Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren and Joe Biden
could spend 45 minutes just the three of
them talking about exactly how their
healthcare plans would work we would be
able to actually press Joe Biden on how
not progressive his health care plan is
Bernie Sanders would be able to actually
hash out with Elizabeth Warren
okay well Elizabeth if you're open to
Medicare for all but you're also open to
other options give me one of those other
options let's debate in detail how one
of the other options would work but it's
not going to happen we're going to hear
from you no irrelevant nonsense from Tom
Styer and Tulsi Gabbard and Amy
Klobuchar and other people who have no
shot at this it's going to be terrible I
will be watching of course but it is not
going to be a debate that will leave us
drastically more informed in depth about
the positions of the candidates that
actually have a shot of this thing
mistakes all around and unfortunately
the debates seem to be getting worse as
we go not better